ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
needed this visit the leaders of france
germany italy and romania arrived in the
ukrainian capital kiev in what the
ukrainian leader and many eastern
european countries hoped would show
european unity and dispel rumors that
france and germany at least were going
soft on supporting ukraine
after visiting european on the outskirts
of kiev
one of many areas where russia is
accused of committing war crimes in the
initial weeks after the war started
meetings were held before a press
conference in the marinski palace garden
the french president seemed keen to put
the record straight ukraine has to win
this war and maintain its territorial
integrity he said
he promised more weapons
france has since they once publicly
honored its commitments and each time
that i made a commitment to you it's
given rise to a decision and rapid
implementation because we know that it
takes material but is needed quickly
on military hardware germany's leader
chancellor schultz has faced weeks of
criticism from ukraine
for foot dragging on military support he
seemed less equivocal now
at the moment we are training the
ukrainian military with our most modern
weapons the howitzer 2000 and on the
leopard air defense system we've also
agreed to deliver our modern air defense
system the iris-t which is able to
defend a whole city and a specialist
radar system the cobra
and we've agreed a trilateral agreement
with the u.s and the uk to deliver
rocket launches as you can see germany
is providing significant support to
ukraine
schultz agreed with his french italian
and romanian counterparts that ukraine's
candidacy status and potential eu
membership comes with conditions
italian prime minister mario draghi
agreed that ukraine must commit to
profound reforms he said
i want to say today that the most
important message of our visit is that
italy wants ukraine in the eu
today is a truly historic day ukraine
has felt the support of four powerful
european states and in particular
support for our movement towards the
european union italy romania france and
germany are with us all four leaders mr
draghi mr johannes mr macron and mr
schultz support ukraine's candidacy
of course all relevant procedures must
be followed all eu member states must
join but at our meeting today a big step
was made a step forward his pleas for
increasing amounts of powerful weapons
from his western backers seems to grow
louder every day
ukraine's eventual and potential eu
membership seems to be taken seriously
but with strict conditions and a very
long timeline there was consensual
agreement though on what's being
described as russia's sea blockade the
french president saying that this was
all russia's fault and moscow has a duty
to help solve it charles stratford al
jazeera kiev